dr gabor mate is a renowned speaker and
a best-selling author known for his
expertise on dealing with stress and
addictions he went from surviving the
holocaust and emigrating to canada with
his family when he was a kid to working
for over a decade with patients
challenged by drug addiction and mental
illness and being awarded the order of
canada for his groundbreaking medical
work and writing
need motivation watch top 10 with
believe nation 10.99
hey it's evan carmichael and i make
these videos because you are probably
the most
ambitious person in your circle but you
know you're capable
of more and you get that push by
surrounding yourself with the best
so today let's learn from one of the
best dr gabor mate and my take on his
top 10 rules of success
enjoy okay let's kick it off with rule
number one live authentically
let me tell you about a friend of mine
who lives in calgary
her name is shannon duke and shannon is
48 years old now
and when she was 37 she was diagnosed
with stage 4
breast cancer the stage four meant that
the cancer was already in her bones by
the time it was diagnosed
at that time she had two young children
age one and three and married to a
well-to-do businessman she herself
was a very high functioning executive
for microsoft in calgary
and then she's diagnosed she had the
perfect life perfect marriage perfect
home of course
and then she's diagnosed and healthy
physically you know fit
always ate well and then she's diagnosed
with stage short breast cancer
and
she has a transformation
now she gets the best medical advice she
can get anywhere in north america and
she traveled to new york and elsewhere
she got the best medical treatment and
with that she was given one year to live
because that's the prognosis stage four
despite the medical treatment chances
are you'll be dead in one year
now a year ago in february
just a year ago now shannon traveled to
the napa valley of california with some
of her friends
and they celebrated her 10th year
survival and her
47th birthday and the transformation
that she experienced was
that when she was diagnosed and started
paying attention she realized that her
life had not been her life
because she was sexually abused as a
child
and uh her response to the abuse was
of course as many children will
experience
it can't be about the adults it's about
me so if i would if this terrible thing
happened to me i must be a very bad
person
so i had to be very good to compensate
so the good daughter who doesn't talk
about it doesn't disturb the waters
the good employee the good student the
good wife who doesn't talk about the
husband's addiction issues because that
would again disturb the waters and when
she's diagnosed and she decides she
wants to live she says the hell with all
this perfection and goodness
and she confronts her family a virgin
about the abuse that she had endured and
she confronts her husband
and she starts leaving an authentic and
she leaves the job by the way which
wasn't her
wasn't really expressing who she was now
st
11 years later the cancer is still in
her bones but it's completely inactive
but she knows that if she wants to stay
alive she needs to stay authentic
so that i believe that
many of these issues are reversible and
i
i'm not promising a cure here to anybody
but shannon really
underwent a major self-journey
and she continues every day to work at
it and she she practices her spiritual
ways which she ignored all those years
and she pays attention to herself and
she keeps clearing the stuff
out and she is the picture of health
her and i give workshops together
sometime
so that there's ways to get there but
it's a commitment
and of course it might threaten the
attachment relationships
so that's always your call rule number
two don't
ignore the trauma so the drama of the
gifted child is by a
swiss german jewish swiss
psychotherapist named alice miller
who was for three decades a
psychoanalyst
but she realized that the freudian
psychical psychoanalytic method
wasn't helping anybody get better
because it ignored trauma
so the drama of the gifted child the
german title of which was
prisoners of childhood was really all
about the fact
that stuff happens to us as children
negative things happen
then we adapt to those things by taking
on certain defensive ways of being
and then we leave the rest of our lives
from those defensive modes
so we're not actually experiencing the
present we're constantly reliving the
past
from a perspective that we acquired when
we were helpless and vulnerable children
and when she says the gifted child she
means the sensitive child
so the more sensitive the child is the
more he or she feels the pain and stress
of the environment
and the more affected they are and the
more that shapes their lives
and that book came along for me when i
was in my 40s and i was a successful
doctor
and and and and i was a father but i was
depressed i was anxious
i was a driven workaholic you wouldn't
have known that when you saw me on a job
but inside me i was discouraged i had
difficulties in my marriage
with my children i felt they were afraid
of me and they were
because of my rages and that book helped
me understand
it was the first book to help me
understand where all that came from
so that was for me as for many other
people a seminal
read and really my whole work
since then has been to help liberate
people from that prison
that childhood often imposes on so many
of us
rule number three reconnect with
yourself given that value
just to take your example is an
essential human quality
as we both agree then your disconnection
from your value
is your trauma so something happened
and unless until we deal with what
happened where you lost that connection
to yourself
we can't really help you with the
addiction so the addiction is a
secondary problem
just by teaching your behaviors or
mantras or or trying to talk you into
recognizing that your value it's never
going to work
we've got to deal with the underlying
disconnects from yourself that's driving
it
so what i'm saying about addiction is
that it's always an attempt to solve the
problem it's not a primary problem
and that the problem arose out of a
childhood trauma
and that trauma
essentially disconnects disconnects us
from ourselves
rule number four live in the present
moment i
work with people to bring out the truth
of their experience
so that they're no longer prisoners of
their childhood but that they can make a
conscious choice about how to live
in the present moment not based on how
they were programmed in childhood
and but for that you have to do it in a
way that the dog whisperer do
in a very compassionate way otherwise
people just shut down and
and then they they shrivel up and they
protect themselves so
that's what i do also if you want to
have more self-love and unstoppable
confidence
check out my 254 series they're free the
links to join are in the description
below
you were up and dressed and ready to go
before your parents were up
you know why because you knew something
unexpected was going to happen
that's how we should live our lives
waking up with the understanding
to expect the unexpected successful
people do what they
hate to get to where they want to be if
you're going to speak
effectively you have to know way more
than you're talking about
rule number five be willing to leave
what's the root of the world familiar
family yeah which is to say
you grew up in a very stressed family
yeah that was the environment i don't
know anything about you but
that was you just told me that was the
environment that you grew up in
and and to some extent we recreate
we all recreate the emotional
resonances that we experience as
children so until you're willing to
leave your family in that sense
you're going to keep recreating this
rule number six relook
and recognize in general i believe that
most mental health disorders in fact i
would say almost every mental health
disorder
originates in childhood experience and
originates as a coping mechanism
now if you look at anxiety if i were to
pull a gun on you
you would not be anxious you'd be afraid
as we should be
so when are we afraid
when we're threatened with something
either something bad happened to us or
something that we perceive
as we need as something that we need is
threatened to be taken away from us
now in the early child's life in a young
in a young child's early life anxiety is
an attachment alarm
what is the child's biggest need
attachment with the parent
connection with the parent when the
parents not around
the child should feel some fear that
serves a positive purpose
because when a child feels fear he cries
she vocalizes and that brings the parent
i mean look at her mother cat responding
to the kittens
cries you know immediate and the same
with the instinct
with human beings who are still
connected to the parenting
parenting instinct they will respond to
the child's cry for help
so that fear is adaptive
so it's a coping mechanism but now what
happens
to a person whose parents are taught
by medical experts like i used to
until i learned otherwise or others not
to pick up the kids when they're crying
now that natural fear
that causes the crying that brings the
parent
which ends the anxiety is embedded in
the child
so what begins as a coping mechanism now
becomes generalized
so under certain circumstances there
should be fear and anxiety
but when i have this anxiety when
there's no immediate threat
what is that about it's not a response
to
anything external it's the embedded
anxiety that i
developed as a child now
in a society that makes people more
isolated all the time
that where where human social contact is
replaced by
the rather cold and and impersonal world
of the internet
and when people under genuine threat
where young people
have less opportunity for meaningful
employment and belonging and a sense of
purpose
than the you than their parents used to
there's
more general threat now when that
general threat hits people
who are in childhood
over immersed in anxiety that's not
relieved by the parent coming to help
them
now you've got an anxiety situation so
when it comes to your friends with
anxiety
i would get them to look at their
childhoods
and to recognize that that anxiety is
really
the cry of some desperate childhood part
of themselves for help
and and to learn to get help with that
part
not to not just take tranquilizers or to
drink booze not to feel the anxiety
or not to go on the internet to to sue
themselves or to
escape momentarily but to actually see
that that anxiety is a normal response
on their part
to what actually happened to them and
that it can be
relieved and recovered from if they look
at its sources
rule number seven find your true self
there's the false self and there's a
real self
yeah and so you're talking about is the
loss of the ego
uh the ego itself now the ego itself
not to criticize it but just to describe
it
is the set of defensive compensations
and identifications and false
assumptions
that we develop because we lost
connection to our true self
and that egoic self once it develops to
protect you against pain as it does in
childhood
it's very tenacious it does not let go
of you
uh because um
it's desperate for survival because it's
survival is associated with your
survival
in childhood so it doesn't let go easily
so when you're talking about the loss of
the self you're talking about the loss
of that egoic self
that's what they call ego death now then
there's a larger self
that look at the very word
in addiction healing is recovery
recovery means to find something again
that's what it means to recover
something when you ask people what did
you find when you recovered
99 of the time people say i found myself
which means to say that the true self
the authentic stuff was never lost
damaged or
or destroyed but it was
obscured it was obscured by the false
self
so yes to get the true self you do have
to use the new self which is what jesus
talked about by the way
when he talked about that unless you're
born again you can't enter the kingdom
of god
now he wasn't talking about psychedelics
he was just talking about uh
he might have been well i i don't
necessarily think so but
and and and and i know that we're
speaking in the context of a conference
and psychedelic healing so we can
certainly talk about psychedelics
but it's important to emphasize that
that process of of of
uh recovering the self of reconnecting
is not dependent on any one particular
modality no
there's all kinds of roots to it
psychedelics in the right context being
a particularly powerful way but
it's really not the only way so but but
that loss of the and and
and uh and jesus even said also said
that
those that cling to life will die and
those that are willing to die will live
i i'm rephrasing him but the words to
that effect
i could find them on my cell phone
because i have them recorded on it
but basically saying that the egoic self
has to die for the true self to live
rule number eight understand the source
of your pain
right away when you understand that you
get that the addiction
wasn't your problem your addiction was
your attempt to solve the problem
and the real question is how did that
problem develop how come it's seven
billion humans in the world
you felt lonely how come you lack the
sense of agency control
authority uh in your life why were you
in so much emotional pain
and everything you've said the
loneliness the lack of power
uh lack of control the anxiety these are
forms of emotional pain
so my mantra on addiction is not why the
addiction but why the pain
and this is where we can talk more about
it but as
you and i both know the the current
model of addiction
is either the legal one which says it's
a choice that people make and therefore
we have to punish them for it
or it's a medical one in which case it's
an inherited brain disease
but it isn't either of those things
where it actually is
is an attempt to solve a human life
problem that of emotional pain
loneliness distress anxiety whatever it
is
and the real question then is what
happened in my life or your life joe or
everybody else's lives here that we
incurred pain and then how do we deal
with our pain
because the addiction itself magnifies
the pain it it it multiplies it
it it uh it increases it exponentially
so
uh it begins in pain as eckhart tolle
the spiritual teacher says
addictions begin in pain and they end in
pain rule number nine
look deeper the example i often give is
and that can lead to both very positive
and very difficult
consequences for example if i tap you on
the shoulder right now
you wouldn't feel any pain at all but if
you were not wearing a shirt and and
your skin was exposed
furthermore if you had a burn on your
shoulders so your nerve endings were
close to the surface
if i attacked you with the same force
you'd feel extreme excruciating pain
even though the external event was no
different
right so sensitivity magnifies the pain
that we have
sensitivity also leads to more
creativity
so very often the most creative people
also have the most pain
which is why so many creative people
escape from their pain through all kinds
of dysfunctions like addictions and so
on
so there's a real link between
creativity and sensitivity
and creativity and and sensitivity and
suffering at the same time
that's the first point i would make now
the other thing goes back to what you
said about
these people that you know who are high
performers look at that word performers
what does it mean to perform one meaning
of it is to put on a show
sure that's one meaning and i would have
been one of these people who was a high
performer
uh in other words looked at from the
outside
a successful funny doctor director of a
palliative care unit at a major hospital
national columnist for canadian
newspaper writing medical columns
performing at a high level and inside
[Music]
again anxious frustrated depressed
discouraged
and in my personal life a lot of
suffering
so a lot of people who perform well
are actually deeply troubled inside and
of course there's many famous examples
of that
some of the greatest performers like
presley
or melanie monroe and any number of
people like the name
that's what they were they were
performers and even from themselves they
hid their own suffering
and rule number 10 the last one before
very special bonus clip
is deal with the core issue was talking
to a colleague of mine jamie
where are you jamie you're here
somewhere new
she's a physician from detroit oh dr
jamie hope you in the room oh she's
i think she's in the uh genius lounge
okay all right yeah yeah so she
works in the emergency ward at detroit
hospital
and she graduated in
05 from medical school in michigan
and after how many lectures on emotional
trauma did you receive
not a single one how many lectures on
how the human brain develops in
interaction with their
and with the environment that you
receive not one which is the same with
me when i went to medical school
i don't know 40-yard years ago and so
what i'm saying is that the the medical
world
utterly misunderstands the problem and
don't get any training
in understanding uh human psychology and
the same thing is true of
many of the programs where people go for
addiction so they never deal with the
core issue
they only deal with the the behavior of
addiction but the behavior
is only the symptom now i've got a
really special bonus clip that i think
you're gonna enjoy
but before that it's time for the
question of the day i want to know what
was your single
biggest takeaway from this video and
write down in the comments below
when you're going to take action on that
takeaway
this week when you schedule in what day
what time and what place you're going to
take action
you have a 91 chance of actually
following through
compared to just 35 if you just got
motivated
but never created a plan and when you
share your plan and have accountability
you give yourself an even higher chance
of following through
so in the comments below write down your
single biggest takeaway as well as your
specific
plan of action because i want to
celebrate with you
the point i'm making is that a lot of
addictions are actually self-medications
for specific conditions
like in your case now atd every again
the medical mantra on add
and i was diagnosed in my 50s and and
two of my children were diagnosed
afterwards the medical
uh mantra is that it's a genetic brain
disease well it isn't genetic and it's
not a brain disease
um when you look at the tuning out the
absent mindedness
of add why do we have that capacity to
tune out do you think
nature gives us that capacity we all
have that capacity to dissociate
to tune out why well
it's very simple if i were to
threaten you right now stress you abuse
you
verbally you would
the number of options available to you
one would be to get up and leave
which is called flight or you could
stand up and assert yourself and tell me
to stop
which is called fight and if you
couldn't do either
given that how many hundreds of people
are here uh there's about 400 between
both rooms
okay so there's 400 people here you
could ask for help
those would be the functional options
hey if you want more top 10 rules videos
they are no longer on this channel i
have a dedicated brand new channel just
for them
if you want to check it out go subscribe
the link is right there next to me
lots of great content go there go check
it out and continue to believe
and i'll see you there